a power suit moment for tonight
absolutely well a Power Jacket moment
yeah it's a little short you know so we
have to make sure we give a little leg
but it works right you and I forgot the
pants at home yes but I've got the type
sorry about that uh congratulations I'm
sure you've heard it so much you know it
never gets old really oh the fact that I
won an Emmy you deserve it thank you
best supporting actress come on Abbott
Elementary that will never ever get old
or be old for me well I'm curious now
that you are Emmy winner Cheryl Lee
Ralph how if at all does that change
your approach to work well I can tell
you one thing it does not change my
approach to work at all I love what I do
it is my passion it is what I'm so happy
that I get to wake up at four o'clock
every morning and go do with about a
hundred screaming kids but I love it
that much I have a great cast a great
crew and a wonderful working environment
for an actor a performer it doesn't get
much better than that
you're the most talented person in the
world but it's your humility that truly
just I don't know it just does something
to me so we got to talk about this big
moment coming up Rihanna casts you in
the Savage Fenty runway show how does
that happen does Rihanna personally call
you yeah you get a phone call you get a
phone call and an invitation asking will
you be Savage on the runway and I was
like uh
yeah yes okay so please walk me through
that day on set is Rihanna giving you
Direction what was it like she has the
most incredible team they're very
knowledgeable they you know I always say
that the vibe starts from the very top
so they really work very hard to be
accommodating and just into you are you
comfortable what do you need this that
and the other they made sure my lingerie
was just nip tucking all the right and
perfect places and I was like magic and
then burn a boy performed and I got to
meet Burna Boy and his mom such a nice
young man I love it yeah when Rihanna
sees you in your Savage Fenty lingerie
what was her reaction what was your
reaction oh I love me yeah I loved it
what a season of life you're in you're
winning Awards you're doing really
meaningful work you're serving looks and
Glam all over your social media and in
real life I think my daughter my
daughter is my stylist really yes Ivy
Coco she does she's been doing an
incredible job she went from strength to
strength and she's just killing it well
shout out to Ivy and I'm just curious
how does this season of Life stack up
against the rest I have to tell you this
is like icing on the cake and it was a
beautiful delicious cake to begin with
so right about now I am just so thankful
to God for having kept me relevant all
these years to be in people's hearts and
minds and to be able to continue to do
what I truly truly love with people that
are some kind of wonderful you're in
your Prime baby you're in your Prime
thank you and The Best Is Yet To Come
foreign